there is something wrong with identity
Politics As We Now perceive it what
seems to be wrong is that people seize
an oppositional identity always say I am
this thing whatever it might be
transgender woman anything with which I
oppose the rest of you you know I'm
standing for that against you all I
don't take hold of the the identity that
would reconcile them with others and
that is what we should be putting in the
place of identity Politics the real
identity the identity that we share
rather than the one that puts it at
logger us at loggerheads with each other
resentment is so much easier than love
you know love requires you to forgive
the faults of the other to be giving and
forgiving whereas hatred has no cost at
all